The people defining what was called a
Standard Generalized Markup Language,
SGML, they took over the pointy-bracket
notation and actually used it within
documents themselves. It leads back into
computer science principles in so many
many ways and there has been so much
confusion. So I suppose you could say what
this episode is about is: SGML, HTML, XML --
what's the difference?
Or are they all the same?  No!  They're not
all the same.
Way back in the late 1970s, early 1980s,
a team at IBM
led by a man called Charles Goldfarb -- who
was trained as a lawyer -- came up with the
idea that it would be really useful to
be able to put tags into documents to
say what the component parts of the
document were, like <p> for paragraph
which is now so familiar to us from HTML as
<p> and they came up with this whole
notation for tags -- that's what it comes
down to. It was a tagset notation. People
who see the advantage of this --
particularly if you had a huge
collection of documents that were just
crying out to be structured -- and there
are quite a few of those. It could be
marriage records, it could be
specifications of stuff owned by the
Department of Defense and indeed some of
the earliest users ofp this tagset
technology, and SGML, was the Department
of Defense and a thing called the Text
Encoding Initiative and they were just
going to tag up everything in the world, that
they could see, with a suitable tag set,
to make it easier to access and to
locate what you wanted if it was in a
big database. So that was the overall
idea of it but in order to show you how
this SGML worked let's start straight
away with something very simple. Here is
a sample memo. There is a 'To'
part - it's been sent to Tony Blair. This
is way back in the early years of this
century around about the time of the Iraq
war, I think, is this fictitious memo. It
is from the White
House. The message is as follows and it says: "The
President says; 'Thanks for your support!' "
Simple as that. So there's a 'To' and a 'From' and a 'Body'
- a message body. Now as computer
scientists we realize straight away that
even if it's just a sequence you can
still present it as a left-to-right
structure within a tree. So here's a
structured tree representation
of what we've just informally written
down. The whole thing - look at the top - is
a Memo. And when you look below, in the
tree it says: "Ah! obviously a Memo is a
sequence of a 'To' part followed by a 'From'
part, followed by a 'Body' part. Great!"
Within the 'To' part there's just some text,
It says "Tony Blair". The 'From' part - more text
it's from "The White House". 'Body' part
- I've deliberately made this a little bit more
complicated. I've said that the 'Body' part
can  be, if you like, just a single
paragraph - a <p> and within the <p> there
could be arbitrary mixtures of plain text
"The president says"  or marked quotations
because what I'm going to do is to say
that thing that was in quotes is an
example of a quotation, so that if in
future Sean were to say to me: "Go through
all our memos and dig out the bits
that are quotations, or quoted speech", then
because it's tagged and marked it's so much
easier to pick out, of course. From that
tree, then, how does that translate into
SGML notation?  Don't panic it's very, very
similar to what you're now familiar with
as XML notation. Right! Here is a tag
that says this whole thing is a Memo and
this is where it begins. The <TO> tag - it's to
Tony Blair, but being a good boy I must
remember to end the </TO> tag. <FROM> the
White House, end of the </FROM> part. Here comes
the <BODY>. Now I typeset the thing,
previously, as the word "Message" but this
is just to illustrate that if you're
crawling all over this spec. with a
typesetting engine
you could take the decision that every
time I see the word 'Body' as a tag, I
actually put out the typeset thing
saying 'Message'. I could have said 'Body' but
the tags themselves can trigger
typesetting and stylistic decisions, if
that's what you want to do. So here we
come then:  here's the body of the Memo
and, like I said, it's got to be a
paragraph denoted with a <P>.
Here's the free text that I'm allowed: "The
President says", and here is the nested
quote inside the paragraph, denoted with a
<Q> tag: "Thank you for your support!" end
of quote, end of paragraph, end of
Memo. Now some of you,
eagle-eyed, will immediately be dashing
to the Comments on this video, right now,
hold on!, and will say: "You missed out the
</BODY> tag !". To which the answer is: "Yes
SGML allowed you to do that so long as you
warned it, in the spec. that goes behind
this -- of the legal tags. If you said "I will
optionally make </BODY> be omittable",
then the biblical handbook here says:
"You may specify that you want certain
end-tags to be omittable, provided that
doing so will not lead to ambiguity". And
therein lies a complete nest of vipers.
But in this particular case it's all right,
you could put in and replace </BODY>.
Why did they do this? Well, in Charles Goldfarb's
era you have got to remember
disk space was massively expensive and
-- this sounds stupid but it isn't -- every
single saved end-tag all added up to
so many hundred kilobytes that you didn't
need because it could be assumed and
safely replaced you hoped. So, you know, they
were not off their heads, they were
trying to save disk space.
Here's where we have to try and choose
our words very carefully and say what
you're allowed to say and what youre not
allowed to say, in terms of building
<MEMO> out of this SGML technology. So
let me begin with the bedrock and when I
say SGML technology don't forget what I mean.
It's basically -- SGML
is like specifying the 'punctuation'. It's
saying have any tag you like but the
'punctuation' around it is pointed brackets.
So here's our bedrock. On top of this, using
SGML notation I've devised a MEMO language. So
remember, the right way to say this is
that MEMO is an *application*  of SGML. In
other words it "uses the technology of".
You must NOT say that "MEMO is a subset of SGML",
because they're different things.  SGML
is a meta-notation; MEMO is a
specific tagset. And just to tell you
I wasn't alone, way before me, in
the 1980s there was an
initiative within the US Department of
Defense and I think it was to do with
requisition and stores and stuff like
this. I've even forgotten what the acronym
refers to now. CALS was one of the
earliest applications, very big, of
SGML. They thought it was great. Being able to
tag things with what they are and what they mean.
There was also a more
scholarly initiative, called the Text
Encoding Initiative [TEI]. I mean one can
imagine there's no end of literature ... "Is
this an example of the early-medieval
subjunctive?" You tag it up to say "Yes it is".
Everything was hunky dory. Document
professionals thought this was wonderful. When
computer scientists shouted at them
basically saying "You shouldn't have allowed
omitted end-tags. You've no idea the grief
you will get into"
The answer, I think, to that is: if you're
careful, and if you take advice, you
can avoid the grief. But in a closed
world of document professionals, where very
few people see the markup, this is all
right. Then in the early 1990s
Oh boy! did something happen
that really blew it all wide open and
led to a much wider adoption of SGML.
A certain Tim Berners-Lee came along, in
the early 1990s -- I think it was about 1992
when it was first revealed to an
unsuspecting world, and Tim said: "I like
this SGML and for these Web pages, rather
than invent my own tagging meta-notation, I'll
use the pointed-bracket notation of SGML".
But it was massively, massively successful.
"Yeah, it's great!, Pointy-bracket notation!
Specify our pages! Get 'em all out there!"
Well, the weaknesses in HTML, first of all
because it didn't have a document type
definition to say what was optionally
omissible and what wasn't, Tim had a certain
view about .... well, for example "end of para" <p>
Even nowadays, in an XML-compliant
browser, it's not going to refuse to show
your page because you go from <p> to another <p>
without formally closing off the first para.
It just says: "Oh! I've hit another <p> ; I'm already
in the middle of a <p>. I think I'd
better close off the one I'm doing. Go into
another one. Fine. But there were far worse problems
than that and they really, really came
home to roost within the first 18 months.
In 1994 there was a meeting --  I was there --
at Edinburgh, where all of this came out
into the open. A full furious frank
discussion took place about what was
wrong with HTML, could we ever put it
right? This has to be another story.